the suspect accused of shooting and
killing a man outside a southwest valley
gas station refused to appear in court
we're talking about 22-year-old jesus
javier uribe he was taken into custody
yesterday from a home near the crime
scene joe muller is there now live with
the latest
[Music]
this gas station behind me here was
closed much of yesterday but it is now
back open now that suspect who allegedly
shot and killed someone here in this
parking lot ended up not being in court
you refused to come to court your honor
he refused ok jesus javier uribe is
accused of randomly walking into a gas
station early thursday morning robbing
one person before shooting and killing
another while people in the area were on
edge knowing he was not behind bars
several hours later police got a tip he
was in a nearby home and a barricade
situation started uribe was taken into
custody without incident he was set to
face a judge friday for a number of
charges including murder and attempted
murder a friend of the victim curtis
abraham showed up to court to face the
suspect i think he's disgusting and
vile and
and
he needs to be put away forever he took
curtis's life and
curtis was loved by many people
[Music]
as you can imagine neighbors who live
around here feel a lot better knowing
the suspect is behind bars but one woman
we spoke to today says she still has a
lot of questions and the suspect is due
back in court on tuesday reporting live
joe mohler live local now thank you joe
and the family of the victim curtis
abraham released this statement saying
in part quote our family is broken our
hearts are broken words cannot explain
the pain and anger we feel curtis was a
father son grandson brother beloved
family member and friend
we will hold strong that the justice
system will prove that this monster
knowingly left his home in tactical gear
armed with the intent to kill the
innocent we will grieve his loss forever
we have the full statement on 8 news now
dot com